elles avaient un elles avaient bonsoir
Cyril bonsoir à tous
il est pas là
de la compta il
est beau
hein
je l'ai vu sur
dommage ça commence
à mon cœur comment tu t'appelles
Isabelle c'est que ta fille à côté
Isabelle
de Lorraine de Meurthe-et-Moselle on est
dans le dragée
oui justement et bien Cyril justement
nous habitons à 30 minutes de Verdun
Verdun
il y a des il y a des dragées à Verdun
les spécialistes de la dragée
malheureusement aussi les défaites un
petit peu d'histoire c'était jamais de
mal arrêté juste deux secondes
[Rires]
notre gueule arrête mais tu crois
vraiment que tu vas dire tout ça tu
crois que je vais te donner la parole
oui mais moi
sur RFM tu nous fais pas chier voilà bon
mes chéris qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
hier là il y a eu des échauffourés là
dans le futur oui en fait ce qui s'est
passé c'est que je me suis permise
d'intervenir à votre demande
depuis le tout début de l'émission Sans
délation aucune
[Rires]
passe
la personne
fait du grabuge donc voilà donc oui et
donc depuis 18h ma fille d'ailleurs
Pauline me disait maman j'ai peur il y a
quelqu'un à côté qui est vraiment qui
était particulière
[Rires]
cette spectatrice donc hier soir elle
était installée donc à côté de nous et
elle n'arrêtait pas de parler mais tout
le temps tout le temps avec des des
réflexions très désobligeants
désagréables
vis-à-vis des chroniqueurs sur les
thèmes elle disait quoi sur les
chroniqueurs je vais pas oser le dire
à ce niveau là je suis pressé
[Applaudissements]
ça donne envie de jouer aux dames
tu es célibataire
c'est vrai mais j'avoue également autour
de la table
c'est moi qu'on veut pécho et après
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
90 % des cas c'est souvent comme blague
ça se passe comme moi je suis voilà je
suis pas voilà
[Musique]
non mais c'est vrai que je vous jure que
quand je vous ai vu alors Raymond il est
pas voilà parce que
j'ai dit mais attention Raymond
c'est très gentil merci merci
[Applaudissements]
il est magnifique il a toujours été beau
non
[Musique]
du charisme magnétisme il y a quelque
chose
j'avoue également que j'ai également
toujours craqué sur Monsieur Bernard
Montiel
c'est vous craquez si on va la montée il
faut aller vite
et c'est comme les bonbons tu sais quoi
prends tout mais bon
ma chérie voilà c'est vite parce que
voilà c'est euh faites vite on va se
dépêcher vers Bernard
[Applaudissements]
c'est une barre
scolaire
qu'est-ce qu'on fait on mange ou on
bouge le cul
moi je suis au régime
[Applaudissements]
avec tout le respect que je dois Aurore
que j'aime beaucoup
toujours et même bonsoir Benjamin très
heureuse enchanté
[Applaudissements]
tu peux faire plaisir
je rigole
en tout cas vous êtes très sympathique
Nicolas pernica c'est très gentil
justement merci bonsoir Géraldine
c'est un plaisir nous étions donc
présents hier ainsi qu'aujourd'hui voilà
et nous sommes très heureux de vous voir
à côté
magnifique Guillaume
à la radio bravo
[Applaudissements]
comme Pauline aujourd'hui
Pauline on dirait Valérie Benaim après
pas 3 coups de
Gilles Verdez on t'a reconnu
[Applaudissements]
j'adore on dirait un gars sur les
vignettes Panini
là tu es ça va revenir
merci ma chérie si je peux me permettre
une dernière chose
que tu peux tu peux merci c'est toujours
beaucoup d'émotions d'être parmi vous
parce que vous faites une petite
anecdote il faut savoir que ma fille
Pauline est âgée de 21 ans elle est née
en 2002 je l'ai mise au monde ma
merveilleuse Pauline et elle est née le
premier avril donc première avril 2002
c'était le lundi de Pâques et par
rapport à TPMP
c'est fou parce que j'ai eu le même
problème moi un jour j'ai acheté des des
céréales
c'est un besoin et c'était
l'anniversaire de maître kaker
non mais tu as raison mais c'est super
bravo tu as raison tu as raison c'est
super